بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
اسعد الله مسائكم جميعا
هذا المؤتمر لنضعهم في صوره القهوه
عليه الصلاه والسلام الدوله
[موسيقى]
وجرت ترافق مع هذا مظاهر اثاره الفوضى
والتخريب بعض الاماكن الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
والسلام على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين وعلى انبياء الله الطيبين الطاهرين
اسمحوا لي في البدايه
ان اترحم على زميلي
العقيد
الشهيد عبد الرزاق الدلابيح
اللي استشهد ليله الامس
وهو يقوم بواجبه في منطقه الحسينيه
الشهيد عبد الرزاق لم يكن في الحسينيه
لحمايه املاكه الخاصه
ولم يكن في الحسينيه
لحمايه عائلته
وانما كان في الحسينيه
لحمايه اهلنا
في المنطقه لحمايه اسرهم اطفالهم لتامين
ممتلكاتهم لتامين الممتلكات العامه ليلام
الطفل والمراه والشيخ والمريض امنين الا
انه تلقى رصاصه غادره من يد غادره
في لحظه
تجاهل فيها الغادر كل معاني الانسانيه
والوطنيه
وبالتالي
[موسيقى]
ذهب عبد الرزاق رحمه الله شهيدا نسال الله
سبحانه وتعالى ان يتقبله مع الابرار
والشهداء في عليين
الجريمه بطبعه الحال لن تمر بدون عقوبه
الاجهزه الامنيه تبذل كل الجهد لضبط
الجاني وبسرعه الممكنه
جلاله سيدنا يشعر بالغضب الشديد لاستشهاد
الزميل عبد الرزاق
وتوجيهاته ان يتم ضبط الجاني باسرع وقت
وتقديمه للعداله
اخواني الامن العام ومنذ بدء الاعتصامات
المتعلقه
بالشاحنات او النقل العام تعامل بكل
انضباطيه مع الحدث
ولم يتعرض لاي معتصم سلمي
ولم يتعرض لاي وقفه احتجاجيه
الا انه شاهدنا خلال الايام الماضيه
تطور كبير في اعمال العنف انتهت الى مقتل
زميل عبد الرزاق واصابه عدد من زملاء
هذه الاعلى الاعمال العنيفه
شملت
دراما النار بمؤسسات حكوميه
دراما النار بالمؤسسات خاصه
يعني 48 عمود كهرباء في معان على الارض
وقطع التيار الكهربائي عن عائلات في
البيوت بعضها
مريض ومرض يتطلب ايضا وجود الكهرباء
ما هو ذنب هؤلاء الناس
شو دخل الاحتجاجات على اسعار المحروقات
بانك تقطع طريق وتكسر زجاج شاحنه وتكسر
زجاج باص وتحرق مؤسسه الضمان الاجتماعي
وتوقع عند كهرباء وتقطع الكهرباء عن مناطق
ليس فقط في معاني ولكن ايضا في مناطق اخرى
همم شملتها الاحتجاجات
الحكومه تعي تماما صعوبه
المعيشه اللي يعانيه المواطن يعني احنا مش
عايشين في جزيره معزوله احنا قلنا اخ واخت
وام فيها القرعه عايشين ويعانوا نفس
الظروف اللي بعانه منها كل المواطنين
الاردنيين يعني ما احنا غريبين عن هذا
المجتمع ونعي تماما الصعوبات التي يواجهها
ومقدرينها وبنعرف انه ليس بالامر السابق
ونبذل كل الجهد ممكن للتخفيف من هذه
الصعوبات
لكن يا اخواني العنف لا يخاف من هذه
الاضرار بالممتلكات العامه والخاصه لا لا
لا لا يعني يخفف من اي شيء انت بتعاني منه
بالعكس يزيدها ويزيد صعوبه في تمويلها
اللي بدي اقوله انه بعد ما حدث امس
سيكون هناك اجراءات امنيه مشدده
وسيتم تعزيز القوات الامنيه
فيلم انا اعتقاليه تشهد مثل هذه الاعمال
لن يسمح
لاي شخص ان يستغل الاحتجاجات
والتعبير السلمي اللي احنا نقر فيه
ولا نمانع فيه ونحميه ان يستغل مثل هذه
الاحتجاجات
لاخذ البوصه باتجاه العنف والاضرار
الممتلكات والاضرار بامن الدوله والذهاب
بنا الى حاله من عدم الامن لنا ولاسرنا
والممتلكاتنا العامه والخاصه
ومالاتها الصعبه التي اذا حصلت لا سمح
الله قد يكون النهوض منها صعب
ولذلك
اليوم ليس كا البارحه
اطلب من جميع المواطنين الابتعاد عن كل
الاماكن التي تضم اعمال العنف
فصل الاحتجاجات السلميه
المسموحه والتعبير السلمي عن اعمال العنف
الحكومه ومنذ اليوم الاول منذ الاحتجاجات
تعاملت مع الموقف بحكمه ومن مسؤوليه
يوم الاحد اربعه 12 الشاحنات اعلنت
الاضراب مباشره تم الالتقاء فيها وانا كنت
احد الناس اللي تلتقوا فيهم
قلنا لهم ما هو المطلوب قالوا لنا المطلوب
انه عام المعامله التموين في ما يتعلق
بنقل البضائع قلنا ولكم ذلك وثاني يوم
قالوا بدنا الفوسفات تنزيل النقل وقلنا
ولكم ذلك
ووافقوا اصحاب الشاحنات
ثم حصل بينهم احتجاجات داخليه تم الالتقاء
مع الاطراف اللي يعتقدوا ان النقاب لا
تؤثرهم وقرروا بنفس الطلبات وتم الموافق
عليها بالاضافه الى تشكيل لجنه لبحث كافه
القضايا الفنيه المتعلقه بها يعني الحكومه
ما انتظرت لليوم الثاني
وتم الاتفاق معهم ان يتم فك الاضراب الا
انه وتحت الضغط من الاشخاص اللي حواليهم
واللي بدهم ياخذوا هذا المطلب الى شيء
اكبر من ذلك وذهبوا به الى اعمال العنف
واصبح يتم تهديد سواقين الشاحنات الي بيحب
يمارسوا عملهم كسرت شاحناتهم
بده يشتغل بده ينقل بده يجيب رزق لاولاده
عنده مسؤوليه وطنيه
على طريق الغور
شو ذنبه تعرض هو للاصابه
لماذا لا يسمح للشخص الذي يعتقد ان
مسؤوليه الوطنيه ومصلحته فانه يمارس عمله
طبيعي ان يمارسها واذا انت محتاج وانت ما
بتداوم انت مسموح الحق الاحتجاج والتعبير
لكن الاسم الشديد الطرق تعرضت الى قطع
الشاحنات تعرضت الى تكسير
النقل العام ايضا تم الاتفاق معهم بشكل
سريع على اله تم مضاعفه الدعم المقدم لهم
لكي لا يتم عكس اجور الناقل على المواطن
وايضا داوموا سواقين الا
السائقين نقل عام في بعض المناطق اللي ما
زال تشهد هذه الاحتجاجات
يعني كل ما طلب اعطي
بقصد انه مانخلي الدعم ال ال عمران ينتقل
الى النظام
ثم مازلنا لغايه الان نعاني في الموانئ
وتعاني بعض المخزون في المملكه ويعان
السائقين على الطرقات في نقل البضائع
الكثير من الشركات الوطنيه
قررت ان تتحرك وان تنقل بضائع من العقبه
الى عمان ولكن تعرضت الى الاذى في كل لحظه
هذا الامر لن يسمح به بعد اليوم
المناطق التي تشهد مثل هذه الاعمال ستشهد
تواجد امني كثير وكثيف ويتم الاستخدام
القوه المناسبه لمنع مثل هذه
الخروج على القانون
حق التعبير مسموح
وحق التعبير السلمي مقدر وهو محكوم
بالدستور ونحترمك حكومه
لكن لا يكون هذا الامر يستخدم في اعمال
العنف
الوضع الاقتصادي صعب
صحيح لكن نحن نتامل ان شاء الله سبحانه
وتعالى وهي اسعار المحروقات تنخفض وان شاء
الله نهايه الشهر يكون فيه انخفاض والاشهر
القادمه لتتلوها ايضا يكون فيها انخفاض
وتخف حجه هذه الازمه واحنا نسعى بكافه
الاتجاهات ليس فقط بهذا الاتجاه للتخفيف
من حده الوضع الاقتصادي على المواطن
وهنالك امور هيكليه وهنالك رؤيه اقتصاديه
ان شاء الله انها تاتي ثمرها وهناك تواصل
مع كافه الاطراف التخفيف على المواطن
والحكومه اصعب قرار تاخذ الحكومه يا
اخوانه واسعارها في المحروقات والله
الجلسه اللي تقرر فيها رفع المحروقات انها
اكثر جلسه بتاخذ وقت وفيها مشاهدات لكن
بالنهايه هذه الحكومه تتغلب المصلحه
الوطنيه هسه في ناس يقول لك الحكومه انا
بقول لكم هذه الحكومه تغلب المصلحه
الوطنيه وما بترد عليك اليوم بعد سته اشهر
شو بده يصير فيك
ولو الناس تعرف المقالات اللي لا سمح الله
اذا ما ذهبنا بهذا الاتجاه راح تقول لك
ياريتكم في ذلك تقول
نحن هذا القرار مش قراته في مجلس الوزراء
هذا قرار اكثر قرار يصير عليه اجتماعات
وياخذ وقت
وتغلب فيه المصلحه الوطنيه ما في حكومه
حابه انها تشوف هذا المشهد الي شايفينه
اليوم الاسهل انك تخفض هالمحروقات وتتحمل
مديونيه وتحمل مع الالاتها الصعبه اللي ما
بتحملها وانا قلت الحكي هذا بشهر اربعه
على جزء من النسيج هذا المجتمع وشايفه
حياتي انا اليوم يعني ساكن لا انا بعرف
الهمله لكن بعرف الهم اللي ما تقدر تتحمله
من شان هيك احنا ذهبنا الى رفع اسعار
المحروقات
وقاعدين نعمل على معالجه اثارها الجانبيه
وان شاء الله زي ما قلت لكم انخفاض جاي
لكل الاسعار العالميه تشير ان شاء الله
بنهايه الشهر يكون في انخفاض والاشهر
القادمه ان شاء الله زيها وفي فرص الحكومه
تسعه بكافه الاتجاهات
احنا يعني جلال سيدنا زي ما قلت لكم كان
لديك غضب شديد على اللي حصل امبارح
وكان توجيهاته مدير الامن العام والاجهزه
الامنيه ان يتم ضبط الجاني
تعمل حديثا على ذلك احنا بنعزز
تواجدنا الامن في مناطق اللي تشهد اعمال
العنف وراح يكون في اجراءات قريبه في هذه
المناطق
لكن هذه الاجراءات هي فقط موجهه لمن
يستخدم العنف وهي فقط موجهه لمن يخرب
ويدمر الممتلكات العامه والخاصه ويروح
المواطنين الامن العام جهاز ااا ويحكي
مدير الامن العام قبل شويه تضرر كثيرا في
هذه الازمه وهناك اصابات في في الجنود وفي
الضباط وهناك
ايضا اصابات في الاليات وهنالك حرف لجهاز
الامن العام عن عن واجهه المنوفي الاخير
انا بدي مره ثانيه اكد انه الحكومه ملتزمه
باحترام حريه التعبير
ايه لكن يجب ان لا يختلط حريه التعبير
بالعنف يجب على الاخوان اللي بده يعبر
سلمان انه يبتعد عن المناطق التي تشمل
العنف وتخريب للممتلكات سائرين الله
سبحانه وتعالى لهذا البلد الطيب المعطاء
كل الخير وشكرا جزيلا
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الشهيد
العقيد الدكتور عبد الرزاق الدلابيح الذي
قضى في سبيل الوطن وحمايه هذا الوطن
والمحافظه
ويعلم ويعمل من خلال قانون الامن العام
وعلى راس واجباته
والمحافظه على
ارواح وممتلكات واعراض الناس
وايضا المحافظه على النظام العام
والسنه المجتمعي وان يبقى هذا الوطن
واستقرار لابناء هذا الوطن ولمن هو مقيم
على ارضه سواء كان من الدول الشقيقه او
الصديق
لكن احيانا احنا
بين الحين والاخر يكون هناك اشكال تعبير
ومظاهر التعبير ونحن نحترمه
وهذا حتى التعبير المحفوظ ولكن احيانا
عندما تخرج هذه المظاهر في تصل الى خلال
بالامن والنظام العام يستوجب علينا في
جهاز الامن العام ان نصنع بالواجبات
المنافقين بالقانون وان يعيد الحمل
والاستقرار لذلك
في استخدام
التعامل مع هذا الشكل اللي اصبح يخرج عن
الوضع الطبيعي ولذلك احنا بين الخير
والاخر
يكون هناك مظاهر التعبير لكن احنا الان في
الحادث اللي نحن فيها كما اشار معالي وزير
الداخليه
منذ ان بدات الازمه المتعلقه بالمشتقات
النقطي وتعملت معها الحكومه بشكل ايجابي
وقدمت كل ما يلزم لمثل هذا المطلب لكن
وللاسف انه انحرفت في يوم الثالث عن
المسار واخذت هناك اشكال همم تظهر من
المعبرين من خلال قطع الطريق والاعتداء
على المنشات العامه والحاق الضرر ايضا في
الممتلكات العامه والممتلكات الخاصه
واتعامل على تعطيل حياه الناس وايضا الحق
الضرر في جميع يعني مناحي الحياه خاصه في
المناطق الجنوبيه كما شاهدنا ووصل للحد
حتى انه استخدام العيارات الناريه واطلاق
النار باتجاه الشرطه بشكل مباشر ولدينا
الشواهد على هذا الجانب ولدينا عدد
الاصابات منهم من قضى وتوفى في سبيل الله
الشهيد زميل لرفيق السلام واخرين ما زال
على سرير الشفاء واخرين عودوا وغادروا
ووصل العدد الى 49 حاجه من ضباط وافراد
الامن العام
هذا
الشكل ملفت للانتفاخ ولا يحاكي واقعنا
وطبيع التصرفنا
ايضا هناك عدد للاليات سواكات اليات تدفع
الامن العام تجاوز عدد سبعون اليه وايضا
اليات
لمملوكه للمواطنين ايضا تجاوز عليها ارقام
كثيره تتجاوز ايضا الثمانين 90 عاليه من
كسر زجاج او الاعتداء او حتى الاعتداء على
السواقين والحاق الضرر في مالهم وتعطيل
حياتهم ايضا المنشات الاليات التي كانت
تستخدم
الاعتداء عليها وهناك ارقام بهذا الجانب
لكن احنا همم الحمد لله بنقول مازن احنا
نتعامل مع هذه الحالب ولن نقلوا جهدا ان
نضرب بيدم الحديث على من تسوي الله نفسه
الاخلال بالعمر نحن مكلفين واحكام القانون
انقطعان وواجباته بما يحفظ الامن والسلم
المجتمعي وان يعيد الحياه مستقره لابناء
هذا الوطن
واجبنا الامن العام بالدرجه انه مكافحه
اصبح هذا الواجب اذا حددناه معطل الى جزء
من كوادرنا وان تنصرف عن واجب الرئيسي في
مكافحه الجريمه وخاصه جريمه المخدرات
والكل يعلم انه افت المخدرات هي ابا اصبحت
تقلب مجتمعنا نحن نعمل على مكافاه هذه افه
بكل ما اوتينا من قوه وجود ولكن احيانا
البعض الظروف التي تختلف بعض التصرفات
اللي اصبحت تخرج في مجتمعنا وهي بغير
عادها لكن هذا الجانب احنا مهم جدا زي ما
شاب معاني وزير الداخليه احنا سنتعامل
ونستمر في التعامل ونعمل على تمشيط كل
منطقه
اصبحت تشكل حياه مطلقه لابناءها القاتلين
فيها او تعطل حياه
المواطنين بشكل عام سنعمل بشكل مستمر على
هذا الجانب شكرا جزيلا